this might be one of the coolest and  rarest pieces of anime artwork i have  ever got my hands on what you see here  is a master japanese craftsman making a  traditional wood block print called  ukioe a technique that dates back  hundreds of years to japan's ido period  of one of the most famous moments in one  piece it's the scene from chapter 216 as  the straw hats say goodbye to their  friend vivi reminding her that she's  still part of the crew rightfully so  this print is called nakama no shiroshi  which means a symbol of friendship and  there are only 150 pieces of this  worldwide however if you live in the us  you can actually get your hands on one  of these by pre-ordering it until they  run out so i'm really happy i got my  hands on one of them because